Donc voilà, nous poursuivons notre série sur le thème « La crainte de l'homme ».
C'est donc la troisième leçon qui s'intitule « La peur d'être exposé, rejeté, blessé ».
Donc pour rappel, lors des deux premières leçons, on a d'abord exploré ensemble avec Stéphane et moi-même,
d'abord ce qu'était la peur de l'homme, mais de manière générale.
Puis dans la deuxième leçon, nous avons vu quel est le remède à cette peur de l'homme,
qui est donc la crainte de Dieu, que nous avons aussi abordé de manière générale.
Et donc aujourd'hui, nous allons revenir à la peur de l'homme,
mais cette fois-ci pour l'examiner un peu plus spécifiquement et en détail.
Et donc nous allons aborder trois formes courantes que cette peur peut revêtir dans notre vie,
et qui sont notées ici et dans le titre.
La peur d'être exposé, la peur d'être rejeté, et enfin la peur d'être blessé.
Donc comme je l'évoquais dans ma prière, je précise que nous allons mentionner peut-être
des exemples de situations de vie qui peuvent être sensibles pour certains d'entre vous,
selon votre propre passif ou votre propre vie présente.
Et donc si vous êtes concerné par cela, n'hésitez pas à venir me voir à la fin de la leçon,
s'il y a des points, s'il y a certains exemples de cette leçon qui vous trouble,
qui nécessite clarification ou réconfort ou encouragement.
N'hésitez pas à venir à la fin de la leçon.
Donc notre objectif, non pas seulement ce soir, mais à travers toute cette thématique,
ce cours sur la crainte de l'homme, c'est de constater, je le dis aussi dans ma prière,
un véritable changement dans nos vies.
Nous voulons cesser de craindre l'homme et apprendre à craindre Dieu,
ou si c'est déjà le cas, à craindre davantage ou mieux Dieu.
Et bien sûr, lorsqu'on considère à quel point cette peur de l'homme est enracinée dans notre cœur,
à quel point elle semble faire partie intégrante de notre être,
à quel point on a l'impression qu'on ne peut pas s'en débarrasser,
ce changement que je mentionnais peut paraître peu probable, voire impossible.
Mais Christ nous rassure dans l'évangile de Luc au chapitre 18,
ce qui est impossible aux hommes est possible à Dieu.
Donc avançons dans ce thème avec foi, sur ce sujet qui va nous confronter forcément,
d'une manière ou d'une autre, car nous expérimentons tous d'une certaine manière
dans notre vie la crainte de l'homme.
Donc la première forme de peur de l'homme, de crainte de l'homme,
que nous allons considérer aujourd'hui, c'est la peur d'être exposé par les autres,
exposé devant les autres.
Et c'est en réalité la forme la plus fondamentale, la plus essentielle,
de cette peur de l'homme.
C'est une lutte qui remonte à la chute même de l'humanité, en Genèse 3.
Cette peur d'être exposé a été la conséquence immédiate du péché d'Adam et Ève.
Leur premier réflexe, vous vous en souvenez peut-être,
juste après avoir péché, ça a été un sentiment de honte, l'un devant l'autre,
qui les a conduits aussitôt à se cacher, déjà l'un de l'autre, en s'habillant,
mais aussi à se cacher de Dieu.
Ils avaient peur d'être exposés et depuis la chute, malheureusement,
c'est devenu une caractéristique fondamentale de l'espèce humaine,
de l'expérience de vie humaine que nous vivons tous d'une manière ou d'une autre.
Et pourtant, en tant que chrétien, lorsque nous lisons la parole et aussi Genèse,
le tout début de Genèse, nous savons que ce n'est pas comme ça que nous étions censés vivre au départ.
Dieu ne nous a pas créés avec cette peur de l'homme en nous, avant la chute.
Comment cela se manifeste-t-il dans votre vie, dans la mienne, dans nos vies ?
Une question simple qu'on peut se poser pour découvrir cela, c'est
« Qu'est-ce que je redoute le plus que les autres découvrent sur moi ? »
« Qu'est-ce que j'ai le plus peur qui soit exposé de moi en public aux autres ? »
Ensuite, nous en considérons une deuxième forme, la peur du rejet.
Dans son livre « Quand les hommes ont plus d'importance que Dieu »,
Edward Welch, que je vais citer plusieurs fois ce soir, écrit la chose suivante.
« Etroitement lié à la peur que les gens découvrent ce que nous sommes. »
Il y a sans doute la raison la plus commune pour laquelle nous sommes contrôlés par les autres.
Ils peuvent nous rejeter, ils peuvent nous ridiculiser, ils peuvent nous mépriser.
Tout cela, c'est la peur du rejet.
Ils ne nous invitent pas à leur fête, ils nous ignorent, ils ne nous apprécient pas,
ils ne sont pas satisfaits de nous, ils nous refusent l'acceptation, l'amour ou la reconnaissance que nous espérons pourtant d'eux.
Et en conséquence de ce refus de leur part, nous nous sentons dévalorisés. »
Fin de citation.
Parfois, ou souvent peut-être, dans notre cœur, nous calculons ce qui nous présentera sous notre meilleur jour,
ce qui nous fera paraître le plus important, le plus respectable.
Et c'est cela finalement, ce calcul, qui traduit la peur du rejet par les autres.
Et troisième et dernière forme que nous allons voir, la peur d'être blessé.
Et donc, bien sûr, je précise que ces trois formes de peur peuvent être liées entre elles.
Par exemple, la peur d'être exposé aux autres découle de la peur d'être rejeté
après que les autres aient constaté ce que nous sommes ou blessé,
que ce soit physiquement ou émotionnellement comme nous allons le voir.
Mais la solution pour toutes ces peurs, ou ces formes de peur, ces facettes, est la même.
Comme nous l'avons vu, ou en tout cas mentionné dans la dernière leçon, craindre Dieu.
En Matthieu 10, verset 28, Jésus dit
« Ne craignez pas ceux qui tuent le corps et qui ne peuvent tuer l'âme.
Craignez plutôt celui qui peut faire périr l'âme et le corps dans l'AGN. »
Et malgré ces mots de notre Seigneur, nous craignons le mal que les hommes peuvent nous faire.
Et pas seulement au sens bibliquement sain du terme, comme nous allons le voir dans un instant,
mais comme Jésus l'entend ici, nous craignons le mal plus que Dieu.
Nous craignons d'être exposés, rejetés ou blessés plus que nous craignons Dieu.
Et nous sommes parfois prêts à nous compromettre, à transgresser sa volonté pour éviter ses souffrances.
Et ceci peut avoir des conséquences désastreuses dans nos vies, aura des conséquences désastreuses dans nos vies.
Et c'est justement cela le problème, avec ces trois formes de peur de l'homme.
Un besoin que nous identifions dans notre vie prend le dessus sur notre crainte de Dieu.
Et nous finissons par servir autre chose que Dieu, par être soumis à autre chose qu'à Dieu, à adorer autre chose que Dieu.
Nous tombons dans ce cas précis, dans l'idolâtrie de l'acceptation et de l'approbation des hommes.
Cela finit par compter plus pour nous que Dieu et sa volonté.
Donc voilà, un aperçu de ce que nous allons voir aujourd'hui.
Et donc, nous allons commencer par nous poser cette question, pourquoi avons-nous peur ?
D'où vient cette peur de l'homme ?
C'est-à-dire, pourquoi ces peurs supplantent-elles, prennent-elles le pas sur la crainte de Dieu en nous ?
Ensuite, nous passerons donc en revue chacune de ces trois peurs pour voir à quoi elles ressemblent dans la pratique.
Nous allons donner plus de détails, décrire davantage cette peur de l'homme.
Donc, cela veut dire que ce cours aujourd'hui sera un peu plus descriptif que pratique quelque part.
Nous allons définir pas mal de choses pour mieux les comprendre dans la suite des leçons et mieux mettre en pratique toutes ces choses.
Donc, dans le dernier cours, nous avons vu que la crainte de Dieu est la solution ultime à notre crainte des hommes.
Dans les trois prochains cours, nous allons voir comment cette crainte de Dieu s'applique concrètement à la peur de l'homme et règle concrètement notre peur de l'homme.
Donc, aujourd'hui, il s'agit surtout d'identifier les aires de notre cœur où résident ces différentes facettes de la crainte des hommes.
Et donc, cela veut dire que vous devrez vous examiner avec attention et honnêteté pendant ce cours.
L'ensemble du cours est notamment cette leçon ce soir.
Mon objectif et notre objectif à tous ceux qui enseignent ce thème, ce n'est pas simplement que vous compreniez ces peurs en théorie.
C'est un point de départ nécessaire.
Mais c'est surtout que vous discernez leur présence ou non, si vous êtes déjà très sanctifié, dans votre propre cœur.
Et donc, nous allons commencer par une minute ou deux où je vais me taire, afin que vous puissiez faire un premier point intérieur.
Pendant une ou deux minutes, je vous invite à réfléchir sincèrement à quelle manière la peur d'être exposé, rejeté ou blessé par les autres a tendance à influencer votre vie.
Cela peut être au travail, cela peut être dans votre famille, parmi vos amis, peu importe.
Toutes les aires de votre vie où vous pensez identifier une manifestation de la crainte de l'homme, je vous invite à le noter.
Donc, soit sur le papier que je vous ai donné, soit sur votre carnet, soit sur votre téléphone.
Et nous reviendrons à la fin de ce cours sur ce que vous avez noté pour voir s'il y a eu quelques éclaircissements,
quelques réponses ou quelques réflexions supplémentaires après ce cours.
Donc, s'il y a dans ta vie des domaines où tu penses identifier une crainte de ta part des autres,
crainte de leur regard, de leur avis, des choses que tu fais en fonction de cela,
qui dictent ta manière d'être ou de vivre, je t'invite à le noter.
Voilà, on reviendra dessus à la fin du cours.
Et vous-même, c'est quelque chose que vous pourrez garder après pour vos propres réflexions.
Je t'ai un exemple.
Si au travail, tu ne dis jamais ce que tu fais le dimanche parce que tu as peur de ce que les autres vont penser,
c'est une facette de crainte de l'homme plus que de craindre Dieu.
Si tu as peur de donner ton avis sur l'homosexualité ou l'avortement, c'est de la crainte des hommes plus que de Dieu.
Après, on verra, il y a des façons plus subtiles.
Mais si vous pensez qu'il faut juste être honnête, ça reste privé.
Vous pouvez garder pour vous, évidemment.
Mais essayez avec vous-même d'être honnête, sincère par rapport à cela.
Vous allez plus profiter de ce thème et de cette leçon si vous le faites.
Ok, on va poursuivre.
Vous pouvez continuer à noter, il n'y a pas de souci.
Mais on va avancer.
Donc, on va voir premièrement, répondre à cette question.
Pourquoi avons-nous peur d'être exposés, rejetés ou blessés ?
Ces trois formes de peur ou trois facettes de la peur des autres naissent toutes d'un même problème existentiel.
Celui que, tel que nous sommes conçus en tant qu'homme et surtout en tant qu'homme pêcheur après la chute,
nous ne sommes pas en sécurité.
Si les gens savaient vraiment qui nous sommes au fond de nous, alors ils nous mépriseraient probablement.
Et c'est de là que vient notre peur d'être exposés.
S'ils ne nous acceptent pas, alors notre vraie valeur sera révélée pour ce qu'elle est, c'est-à-dire nulle.
En tout cas, c'est ce qu'on pensera.
Et donc, c'est de là que vient la peur d'être rejetés.
Si nous sommes livrés à nous-mêmes sans défense, nous serons blessés par les autres,
que ce soit intellectuellement, physiquement ou émotionnellement.
Et c'est de là que vient la peur de souffrir.
Donc, pour comprendre pourquoi nous avons ces craintes qui sont inappropriées,
il est important de commencer par considérer pourquoi certaines de ces craintes,
de ces mêmes craintes, peuvent être légitimées bonnes parfois.
En quoi ces mêmes peurs sont-elles parfois appropriées ?
Eh bien, pour commencer, l'écriture décrit différentes situations dans lesquelles il est bon de chercher à plaire aux autres
et à obtenir leur approbation.
Ce que nous faisons souvent d'une mauvaise manière pour éviter l'exposition, le rejet, la souffrance.
Et voici quelques exemples où rechercher cela est décrit comme une bonne chose par la parole.
Le désir d'être honoré.
Un désir qui toutefois ne va pas dépasser l'amour pour Dieu, l'amour pour les autres
et le fait de désirer obéir à Dieu et de servir à notre prochain.
Mais Proverbe 15, verset 33, laisse entendre que la crainte de l'éternel enseigne la sagesse
et l'humilité précède la gloire.
C'est-à-dire qu'à la fin du chemin d'humilité, il y a la gloire.
Donc rechercher la gloire, quelque part en soi, même pour l'être humain, n'est pas une chose mauvaise.
Bien sûr, ça demanderait tout un cours d'expliquer comment ça peut être fait d'une bonne manière.
Mais en soi, désirer être honoré, rechercher la gloire n'est pas une mauvaise chose
telle que c'est décrit ici dans la parole.
Un deuxième exemple, dans le cadre du ministère de l'Évangile, du pasteur notamment,
il est bon de chercher à avoir une bonne réputation auprès des non-croyants.
D'ailleurs, ce n'est pas vrai que pour le pasteur, mais pour tous les chrétiens.
Encore une fois, il faudrait développer, mais on peut pour l'instant juste noter
que c'est même quelque chose qui est demandé de la part de Dieu à ses enfants
de chercher à avoir une bonne réputation auprès des non-croyants.
Un troisième exemple, envers nos parents ou les autorités que Dieu place au-dessus de nous.
Nous devons chercher à respecter, à plaire d'une certaine manière, surtout nos parents,
à montrer du respect, de la révérence.
C'est non seulement quelque chose qui est approprié, mais c'est quelque chose qui est commandé par Dieu dans sa parole.
Dans le mariage, il est juste et encore une fois demandé par Dieu dans sa parole
de chercher à plaire à son conjoint.
Et c'est un lien qui passe avant toutes les autres relations.
Mais là, chercher à plaire à l'autre n'est pas vu comme quelque chose de négatif.
Et un dernier exemple, lorsqu'il est demandé de ne pas scandaliser un frère plus faible dans la foi sur certains sujets,
dans un certain sens, on va chercher dans notre attitude à plaire à ce frère, mais d'une bonne manière.
Et au-delà de ces exemples bibliques, la peur peut parfois nous protéger.
Et c'est peut-être le plus évident ce qui concerne la peur de souffrir ou d'être blessé physiquement.
Parce que nous craignons pour notre sécurité, nous faisons attention à l'endroit où nous marchons la nuit,
avec qui nous sommes, et c'est en général une bonne chose.
C'est une crainte aussi qui anticipe le danger, qui nous préserve des blessures, en tout cas qui cherche à faire ça.
C'est une peur qui va nous pousser à anticiper les dangers pour notre famille, à la protéger.
Mais ces mêmes peurs, saines dans ces contextes-là, peuvent aussi devenir dominantes en nous, dans notre vie,
et finir par nous contrôler.
Pourquoi ?
Eh bien au fond, c'est toujours la même réponse, générale en tout cas, à cause du péché.
Que ce soit notre péché, ou celui des autres évidemment.
La grande fausse promesse du péché en Genèse 3.5 qui a été faite par le serpent Adam et Ève,
c'était que vos yeux s'ouvriront et vous serez comme Dieu.
Vous serez indépendants de Dieu, vous serez autosuffisants comme Lui.
Mais qu'est-ce qu'a fait le péché en réalité ?
Il a fait tout l'inverse.
Il nous a rendus peureux, craintifs.
Il nous a retiré toute notre assurance, toute notre paix, notre sérénité,
parce qu'il nous rend moralement insuffisants devant Dieu et devant les hommes.
C'est ce péché-là en nous qui nous fait redouter d'être exposés parce que nous savons au fond de nous
que nous ne sommes pas à la hauteur des standards moraux fixés par Dieu.
C'est le péché qui nous pousse à rejeter les autres et le même péché qui nous fait craindre d'être rejetés à juste titre.
Parce que nous connaissons la vérité sur nous-mêmes et cette vérité n'est pas belle,
n'est pas facile à admettre et à confesser.
Et c'est le péché, encore une fois,
qui se trouve à la racine des blessures émotionnelles ou physiques que nous recevons des autres
parce qu'ils sont eux aussi des pécheurs comme nous.
C'est ce que Jacques exprime dans sa lettre, quatrième chapitre, à partir du verset 1.
D'où viennent les luttes et d'où viennent les querelles parmi vous ?
Sachant qu'il écrit à une église.
N'est-ce pas de vos passions qui combattent dans vos membres ?
Vous convoitez et vous ne possédez pas, vous êtes meurtriers et envieux
et vous ne pouvez pas obtenir, vous avez des querelles et des luttes
et vous ne possédez pas parce que vous ne demandez pas.
Voici la réalité du péché dans nos cœurs, dans nos vies, dans nos relations.
Et c'est également le péché qui est d'abord la séparation d'avec Dieu
qui nous pousse à ne pas lui faire confiance
et à craindre le mal qui pourrait nous arriver plus que de le craindre lui
et surtout plus que de lui faire confiance à lui.
C'est une vision des choses très différentes de celles du monde, n'est-ce pas ?
Le monde dit que le vrai problème, ce sont les circonstances.
Nous avons peur soit parce que les autres devraient mieux nous traiter,
soit parce que nous devrions avoir une vision plus positive de nous-mêmes.
Nous sommes des victimes, des victimes des circonstances passées,
des circonstances présentes de notre vie,
de malédictions héréditaires,
de systèmes sociaux injustes, racistes, inégaux.
Mais voyez à quel point cela est erroné
ou en tout cas insuffisant pour expliquer le problème.
La solution à la peur de l'homme,
ce n'est pas de prétendre que nous ne sommes pas pécheurs
dans un monde qui est évidemment rempli de pécheurs.
La solution consiste plutôt à comprendre la bonté et la justice de Dieu
qui ordonne toute chose dans la vie de gens pécheurs,
dans un monde pécheur.
Alors, comment cela se manifeste-t-il
dans chacune de ces trois catégories de peur ?
Exposition, rejet, souffrance.
Nous allons passer le reste de cette leçon
à les examiner une par une.
Je m'arrête ici si jamais il y a des questions
avant de passer à la peur d'être exposé.
Être exposé, être rejeté, être blessé.
La peur du rejet, pardon, la peur de l'exposition.
Du rejet et de la souffrance.
Oui.
Il y a des cas des fois qui ont tendance à nous empêcher
de dire la vérité évangélique par rapport à,
comme tu disais, par exemple, l'homosexualité,
l'étrangerie, c'est une très plus en plus.
Est-ce que l'on doit s'empêcher de ne pas le dire ?
Ou de suivre le règlement quand on est en cause ?
Bon, on ne doit jamais mentir,
mais Dieu ne nous demande pas non plus de répondre directement.
Quand on nous pose une question, ce que je veux dire,
c'est que si jamais il y avait une discussion
sur le lieu du travail sur ces sujets-là
et qu'on te posait explicitement la question,
connaissant aussi malheureusement les règles au travail
qui deviennent même des lois civiles
pour lesquelles tu peux être condamné,
tu peux tout à fait dire que tu es complètement ouvert
à discuter de ça,
mais que tu préfères le faire autour d'un verre
à la sortie du travail.
Et donc, ça te permet, tu ne mens pas,
tu vas répondre,
mais de le faire dans un cadre
qui ne va pas te mettre à mal.
Ce sont des questions complexes
où il faut essayer de tout prendre en compte,
les conséquences que ça peut avoir ensuite
sur tout le reste de ta vie, ta famille, etc.
Donc, là, je dirais tout au tout point
que je suis contre.
Deux ?
Que je suis contre le transjournalisme.
Il faut le dire, mais là,
la question porte plus sur le contexte.
Oui.
Je pense que tu peux tout à fait le dire,
mais en choisissant un autre contexte.
Là, c'est vrai pour plein d'autres sujets.
Il y a des vérités qu'on ne va pas forcément dire
de la même façon ou au même moment
en suivant le contexte.
C'est plus une question de contexte et de forme
plutôt que de contenu.
Tu ne vas pas adapter ta conviction dans la réponse,
mais tu vas choisir le bon moment.
En fait, il faut, même la Bible laisse entendre ça parfois,
qu'il faut qu'on soit rusé aussi.
On sait le monde dans lequel on vit,
une société dans laquelle l'étau se resserre de plus en plus
sur ces convictions-là,
avec des conséquences réelles d'emprisonnement, d'amende.
Quand on est père de famille ou mère,
il faut aussi prendre ça,
toutes ces choses en compte,
qui sont aussi des responsabilités très importantes.
Je pense que prendre soin de sa famille,
ça passe avant de crier tout de suite tout haut au travail.
Si on me demande qu'est-ce que tu penses du mariage
ou de l'homosexualité,
de crier dans l'open space que je suis contre,
de crier, pardon,
ou de répondre tout de suite,
même si c'est sans crier,
que je suis contre,
et de dire à la pause déjeuner
ou plutôt le soir après le travail,
si tu veux, on se voit,
on discute avec plaisir,
il n'y a pas de problème.
Parce que voilà,
perdre son travail,
aller en prison,
avoir des amendes de plusieurs milliers d'euros,
ça peut aussi avoir des conséquences sur la vie de famille
et prendre soin de nos proches,
les préserver,
c'est un commandement très important aussi.
Je pense plus important que de répondre à une question comme ça.
Dans le proverbe,
l'humanité précède la gloire,
est-ce qu'il s'agit d'une gloire,
d'une réussite ou d'une reconnaissance juste ?
Précise un peu,
reconnaissance juste et réussite.
Dans le sens où,
une juste reconnaissance de notre
soi,
de notre statut,
notre personne,
de quoi il s'agit exactement ?
Je pense que c'est une phrase qui résume la vie de Christ,
par exemple,
en tout cas sur terre.
C'est d'abord humilié,
il a marché sur ce chemin d'humiliation jusqu'à la croix,
avant d'être élevé et glorifié.
Et c'est une sorte de principe quasiment créationnel.
Quelque part,
c'est ce que Adam devait faire.
Il devait d'abord vivre en tant qu'homme.
Bien sûr,
ça a été la plus belle créature de Dieu sur terre,
mais c'était quand même,
il vivait sur terre,
il devait faire des choses,
il devait travailler,
il devait mériter sa récompense éternelle.
Donc,
il devait,
d'une certaine manière,
vivre avec une certaine humilité,
en tout cas plus humblement qu'après,
pour pouvoir justement être glorifié plus tard,
pour pouvoir vivre de manière plus digne et plus élevée plus tard.
Donc,
c'est une sorte de principe,
comme je disais,
quasiment créationnel,
c'est-à-dire inscrit dans la création,
que le travail doit précéder le repos,
que l'œuvre doit précéder la récompense,
que l'humilité doit précéder la gloire.
Moi,
j'ai vu l'incide de la précéder,
je le voyais plutôt comme,
pour une vue eschatologique,
nous serons glorifiés,
une vie d'humilité,
et nous serons glorifiés après.
Je le voyais plus comme ça.
Non,
mais c'est vrai aussi,
c'est juste que c'est un sujet très dense,
et la gloire et être glorifié peut avoir plusieurs sens,
surtout si on parle de crise,
de nous,
et même juste pour nous,
ça a plusieurs sens.
En tout cas,
l'idée là,
c'est ça.
C'était juste un point rapide pour dire que,
dans des contextes précis,
ou un contexte précis en tout cas,
rechercher la gloire n'est pas quelque chose en soi mauvais.
Quelque part,
c'est ce qu'on recherche tous en tant que chrétien.
La question,
c'est comment,
on sait comment on va l'avoir,
c'est-à-dire c'est ancré,
c'est parce qu'on est uni à lui.
Pardon.
Mais on suit ce chemin de souffrance et d'humilité,
voire d'humiliation,
à sa suite sur terre,
pour pouvoir vivre la vie éternelle,
de gloire et de profusion,
etc.
Donc,
quelque part,
c'est ce qu'on recherche,
vu que c'est le but de notre vie.
Voilà,
merci.
Ah,
allez,
une dernière.
Non,
après,
c'est pour vous,
moi.
Oui,
c'est toujours bien de réfléchir à ce qu'on va dire,
plutôt que de parler tout de suite.
Donc,
si on te pose directement la question
et que tu ne sais pas comment répondre sur le moment,
tu peux tout à fait dire que tu dois d'abord réfléchir
et tu répondras plus tard.
Et si on ne t'a pas demandé à toi,
mais que tu as juste entendu la discussion,
que tu étais là quand ils en parlaient,
tu n'es pas non plus commandé par Dieu
d'intervenir forcément dans la conversation.
Donc,
tu peux écouter,
réfléchir,
et si plus tard,
tu as les idées plus claires sur le sujet
et que ça se présente,
tu peux l'aborder.
Merci.
Voilà.
Donc,
merci pour vos questions.
C'était très intéressant.
On va continuer donc avec le point 2,
la peur d'être exposé.
Donc,
à nouveau,
Edward Welch écrit la chose suivante.
Je crois que c'est dans le même livre.
« Chaque jour est Halloween.
Mettre nos masques fait partie de notre rituel matinal,
tout comme se brosser les dents ou prendre le petit déjeuner.
sans les masques,
pardon,
sous les masques,
se cachent des personnes terrifiées à l'idée d'être démasquées.
Et en effet,
les masques et autres couvertures seront un jour retirées.
Et si nous nous sentons exposés au regard des autres,
alors nous serons terrifiés et dévastés par le regard de Dieu.
Et une manière d'éviter le regard de Dieu consiste à vivre comme si la peur des autres
était notre plus grand problème.
Ce sont eux qui sont grands,
ce sont eux le grand problème
et pas Dieu
ni son avis sur nos vies. »
Fin de citation.
Enfin, j'ai un peu commenté à la fin.
Et donc, c'est bien là le problème auquel nous sommes tous confrontés.
Nous craignons d'être exposés parce que nous sommes pécheurs.
C'est ce qu'on a vu dans le premier point.
Nous ne voulons tout simplement pas que les autres nous voient tels que nous sommes réellement,
en tout cas dans cette vie,
à cause du péché,
imparfait,
décevant,
rempli d'imperfections.
À quoi ressemble cette peur d'être exposés ?
Voici quelques manifestations courantes qu'on peut retrouver dans notre vie.
Premièrement,
nous nous cachons et nous nous camouflons.
C'est un peu l'idée du masque qu'on vient de voir.
Comme Adam et Ève,
juste après leur chute,
face au regard des hommes et aussi de Dieu,
ils ont cherché à se cacher et à se camoufler.
Donc, par exemple,
la peur d'être exposés peut se cacher derrière une tendance à idolâtrer le travail.
C'est juste un exemple parmi beaucoup d'autres.
Pourquoi c'est si difficile de dire non,
par exemple,
au travail lorsqu'un supérieur nous demande une mission particulière,
quand c'est légitime de dire non,
soit parce qu'on est surchargé,
soit parce que ce n'est pas notre domaine de compétences ou autre ?
Eh bien,
on n'arrive pas à dire non,
alors que ce serait légitime,
parce qu'on doute que le vrai nous,
sans cette étiquette qu'on veut garder sur notre front d'employé modèle,
soit suffisant.
Nous avons peur de perdre notre valeur
si nous perdons cette étiquette
que l'on veut absolument garder d'employé modèle,
qui dit oui à tout,
qui sait tout faire.
Deuxièmement,
nous fuyons.
Peut-être que vous vous perdez dans des rêveries
ou dans des fantasmes.
Peut-être que vous vous réfugiez dans Internet,
dans certains aliments,
dans certaines habitudes alimentaires.
Peut-être que vous vous perdez dans
les jeux télévisés,
les films,
les séries,
les jeux vidéo,
les livres
ou toute autre passion
qu'on pourrait lister.
Nous fuyons nos responsabilités,
nous fuyons la réalité.
Et il est souvent très éclairant
de relier ce besoin d'évasion,
comme on l'appelle,
à la peur sous-jacente d'être mise à nu
en étant pleinement nous-mêmes,
pleinement dans nos responsabilités,
pleinement dans ce que nous sommes en réalité.
Et non pas une rêverie,
non pas un fantasme.
Troisièmement,
et c'est plus subtil et plus vicieux quelque part,
nous cherchons à exposer les autres.
Alors, je ne dis pas que tout le monde fait ça
dans cette salle,
mais ce sont des possibilités réelles
pour chacun d'entre nous.
Nous cherchons à exposer les autres.
Ironiquement,
nous tirons parfois du plaisir
à voir les autres
et leurs failles,
leurs problèmes
être dévoilés et mis à nu.
Et c'est ce qui peut expliquer
certainement le succès
d'une presse
qui vit de ça.
Les presses people,
les presses à scandale,
tout ce qui est
révélations de presse,
paparazzi, etc.
Parce que,
en tout cas pour ceux
qui pensent ainsi,
qui font cela,
leur propre honte
semble alors diminuer
à leurs yeux.
Parce qu'ils la comparent
à celle de quelqu'un d'autre
qui leur semble plus grande.
Donc, ils se rassurent
en se disant
qu'ils ne sont pas les pires.
Voilà.
Ce qui peut expliquer
la satisfaction
vicieuse et malsaine
que nous avons
de constater
l'exposition
des autres
et comment nous pouvons
nous en servir
pour nous rassurer
par rapport à nous-mêmes.
David Wells,
un autre auteur,
écrit dans
Losing our virtue,
donc perdre notre vertu.
Je ne pense pas
qu'il existe en français,
le livre.
La télévision
et le cinéma
ont fait pencher
la balance
de la vie privée
vers l'exposition
publique,
de la pudeur corporelle
vers la nudité
publique.
Nous voulons voir
la famille
dont le fils
a été assassiné.
Nous voulons
contempler leur chagrin.
Nous pensons avoir
le droit de savoir
ce qu'ils savent,
de ressentir
ce qu'ils ressentent.
Et dans les films,
le public américain,
mais c'est vrai aussi
pour le public français,
veut voir de la nudité
et regarder
des scènes de sexe.
Un sentiment de honte
qui autrefois protégeait
ce qui est privé
et intime
a aujourd'hui
pratiquement disparu.
Balayé par notre vie,
notre envie,
pardon,
de tout partager,
par notre fin voyeuriste
de tout savoir,
de tout connaître,
de tout regarder.
Et je pense que
ce sont des mots
qui sont vraiment
à propos
pour nos générations,
notre société,
à l'heure
où nous avons
un divertissement
à outrance
des réseaux sociaux
omniprésents,
de la pornographie
de masse
et de l'information
en continu.
Où ces tendances
de crainte
d'être exposées
apparaissent-elles
ou peuvent apparaître
dans notre vie ?
Elles peuvent apparaître
dans le privé
lorsque nous faisons
des choses
que nous ne voudrions
surtout pas
que d'autres découvrent.
Il y a une phrase
qui dit
on connaît
un homme
véritablement
à ce qu'il fait
chez lui
dans le plus
secret des secrets.
Et si nous faisons
dans ce secret des secrets
des choses
qu'on ne voudrait
surtout pas
que les autres découvrent,
eh bien,
ça manifeste
une crainte
d'être exposé
qui est légitime.
Mais ça montre
qu'on a un problème.
À la maison,
donc un peu plus large,
mais toujours
dans le privé,
dans les relations proches,
plus vous êtes intime
avec quelqu'un,
plus vous redoutez
qu'un jour,
il voit
qui vous êtes vraiment.
Et d'ailleurs,
plus c'est probable
qu'il voit
qui vous êtes vraiment.
Je pense que tous ceux
qui sont mariés
depuis plusieurs années
ont pu constater cela.
Au travail,
ce moment où,
comme dans l'exemple
que je donnais,
vous avez peur
que votre supérieur
réalise que vous n'êtes
pas aussi compétent
qu'il le croyait,
que vous n'êtes pas
finalement l'employé modèle
qu'il pensait
ou que vous prétendiez être.
Et cela se manifeste
donc souvent
par des réactions émotionnelles
disproportionnées
en cas d'échec
ou de remarques négatives
de la part de nos collègues
ou de nos supérieurs.
Et même à l'Église,
pour donner un dernier exemple,
peut-être surtout à l'Église,
peut-être,
nous portons des masques spirituels
pour impressionner les autres,
en surjouant la sainteté,
une sainteté qui n'est pas aussi réelle
dans notre vie,
en ne confessant pas nos péchés
devant les autres.
Et nous vivons dans la crainte
d'être démasqués,
de perdre ce masque
de chrétien parfait,
idéal.
Et quelle est la réponse
à cette peur d'être exposé ?
La réponse commence par
une mauvaise nouvelle.
Dieu sait tout.
Dieu est omniscient.
Hébreu 4, verset 13,
« Nulle créature n'est cachée devant lui,
mais tout est à nu
et à découvert
aux yeux de celui
à qui nous devons rendre compte. »
Et pourtant,
ce même Dieu,
omniscient,
devant qui tout est à découvert,
ôte notre péché
et notre honte.
Plus loin dans le même livre,
Hébreu 10, verset 12,
Christ,
après avoir offert
un seul sacrifice
pour les péchés,
s'est assis pour toujours
à la droite de Dieu.
Contrairement aux prêtres
de l'Ancien Testament
qui ne faisaient que couvrir
les péchés du peuple
pour un temps
et le leur aussi,
Christ,
sacrifice,
sacrificateur parfait,
les prend sur lui
et les efface
totalement et définitivement
du regard de Dieu.
Et en mettant notre foi en lui,
il ne se contente pas
de couvrir notre honte
pour un temps,
il la prend sur lui,
sur ses épaules,
et il l'élimine
une fois pour toutes.
Nous n'avons rien à cacher
car Dieu sait tout.
Nous ne pouvons rien cacher
à Dieu,
même si nous le voulons,
même si nous essayons.
Et malgré cela,
il nous a aimés
au point de sacrifier
son propre fils,
parfait en tout point,
pour que plus jamais
nous ne soyons
en conflit avec lui,
pour que plus jamais
nous n'ayons encore
à avoir peur de lui
et donc encore moins
des hommes.
Après avoir été ainsi
mis à nu devant Dieu
et revêtus
de justice par Christ,
comment pouvons-nous
encore craindre
d'être exposés
devant les hommes ?
Donc voilà en ce qui
concerne la peur
d'être exposés.
Qu'en est-il de la peur
du rejet,
d'être rejetés
par les autres ?
Nous craignons
d'être rejetés
pour ce que nous sommes,
notre personnalité,
notre niveau d'éducation,
notre poste,
notre statut
socio-économique,
notre genre,
notre origine ethnique,
nos expériences,
nos relations,
la liste peut être
très longue
et nous modifions
notre personnalité
parce que nous pensons
que les autres
nous aimeront davantage
de cette manière,
qu'ils aimeront
davantage notre alter-ego
que le vrai nous.
Nous visons
un certain diplôme,
un titre professionnel,
un emploi
pour être validé,
pour être accepté.
vous craignez
d'être discriminé
à cause de votre race
ou de votre genre
ou toute autre raison
que vous pouvez trouver.
Vous redoutez
le rejet
de certaines personnes
à cause des amis
que vous avez choisis,
par exemple,
ou de vos activités
le dimanche
pour les chrétiens.
La peur du rejet
se manifeste
par un désir écrasant
d'être approuvé
par les autres.
Et comment
ce désir écrasant
d'être approuvé
se traduit dans notre vie.
Encore une fois,
voici quelques exemples.
Ce n'est pas une liste exhaustive.
Nous cherchons
sans arrêt
des compliments.
Et parfois
de manière subtile.
On se rabaisse
de manière hypocrite.
Ce n'est pas ce qu'on pense
vraiment de nous,
mais on rabaisse
ce qu'on a fait,
ce qu'on est devant les autres
en espérant que les autres
vont nous contredire
afin de nous rassurer.
On va dire
« Mais non,
ce n'est pas vrai.
Ce n'est pas comme ça. »
On est demandeur
de feedback
ou de critique,
de retour
de la part
de nos collègues
ou autres,
de nos supérieurs.
En réalité,
dans l'espoir
d'être loué et félicité,
si ce n'est pas le cas,
on ne comprend pas
et on se vexe.
On oriente volontairement
les conversations
vers des sujets
où l'on pense
qu'on sera complimenté.
Des sujets
qui sont à notre avantage.
Si je suis champion
de France de natation
et je parle toujours
de natation,
comme ça,
ça en arrive à moi
et on va me flatter,
on va me complimenter.
Je vais obtenir
des compliments.
On flatte les autres
dans l'espoir
qu'ils nous renvoient
l'appareil.
Et pourtant,
Proverbe 25,
verset 27 nous dit
« Il n'est pas bon
de manger beaucoup de miel,
mais chercher
la gloire des autres
et entre parenthèses
pas la nôtre
est un honneur. »
Donc,
cherchez les compliments.
Le perfectionnisme aussi,
plus rapidement.
Combien de vos situations,
si vous pensez
vous identifier
en tant que perfectionniste,
combien de vos situations
de surcharge mentale
ou d'épuisement
physique même
proviennent
d'un perfectionnisme
qui est motivé
en réalité
non par le désir
d'excellence,
mais par un besoin
d'approbation,
de félicitation
et de louange
de la part des autres.
Une troisième façon
qui montre
que nous désirons
être approuvés,
suivre le troupeau
ou se conformer
à la masse.
Et ce troupeau
n'a pas besoin
d'être nombreux.
Ça peut être
deux ou trois amis
mal choisis.
Et là,
il y a deux exhortations
à faire rapidement.
Aux parents,
d'ailleurs,
il n'y a que des parents,
il n'y a pas vraiment...
Si, il y a des enfants
ce soir.
Ils sont déjà grands,
mais...
Donc, les parents,
nous devons enseigner
nos enfants
à résister
à cette pression sociale.
Cette pression
de se conformer
à la masse
pour être acceptés
et non rejetés.
Nous devons mettre
l'emphase
sur l'acceptation
et l'amour du Christ
pour eux.
Que c'est celle-là
qui compte,
que c'est celle-là
qui dure,
qui ne dépend pas
des circonstances
parce que Christ
a tout accompli
pour qu'elle ne change
jamais.
Leur montrer,
leur expliquer
et peut-être donner
des témoignages
de notre propre vie
où nous avons nous-mêmes
cherché cela
et nous avons été déçus
à la fin
parce que les hommes
ne sont pas fidèles
dans leur compliment,
dans leur approbation,
contrairement à Dieu.
Et les enfants,
donc,
ils doivent apprendre
à faire confiance
à leurs parents.
Leurs parents
qui veulent les protéger
de décisions folles,
insensées
et leur enseigner
ce que signifie
vivent dans la crainte
de Dieu
et pas dans celle
des autres,
même si cela implique
de ne pas être populaire
parmi les amis du monde.
Et cela arrivera
de toute façon
en tant que chrétien.
Déjà,
entre les hommes,
entre les non-croyants,
cela arrive,
mais nous avons
en nous
et dans notre vie
une raison évidente
pour que cela arrive.
Et nous devons prendre
du temps
avec nos enfants
pour expliquer
toutes ces choses
qui,
dans certaines périodes
de leur vie,
seront extrêmement
importantes.
Et souvent,
ce n'est pas tant
la pression des autres
que notre désir
à nous
d'appartenir
à un groupe privilégié,
à un club privé,
de se sentir spécial,
de se sentir
à part des autres,
de faire partie
de la bande
des gens stylés,
de ceux qu'on regarde,
qui sont mis en avant.
Est-ce que
notre identité
dépend du fait
d'être
dans un cercle
de proches,
un cercle privilégié,
que ce soit
dans notre entourage,
dans notre travail
ou même à l'Église ?
Ressentez-vous
de la frustration ?
Êtes-vous en colère
d'être exclu
de ces cercles ?
Vous sentez-vous
dévalorisé,
rejeté,
si ce n'est pas le cas ?
Ne pas partager
l'Évangile
par peur
de la réaction
des autres
Édouard Welch
dit
« Parfois,
nous préférerions
mourir pour Jésus
que vivre pour lui.
Les voyages
missionnaires
les plus populaires
sont ceux
qui nous éloignent
de notre propre quartier.
La Russie,
c'est facile,
vos voisins,
c'est une autre histoire. »
Et une petite parenthèse
à ce propos.
Faites attention
à ceux qui tiennent
des discours
qui veulent sauver
la planète,
arrêter des guerres
à l'autre bout du monde
entre plusieurs pays
mais qui ne rangent
pas leur chambre,
qui sont incapables
de tenir un emploi,
de prendre soin
de leurs proches
ou du SDF
qui vit en bas de chez eux.
Il est toujours plus facile
de feindre l'amour,
la compassion,
l'intérêt,
la préoccupation
pour des personnes
que nous n'avons jamais vues,
que nous ne connaissons pas,
qui vivent à l'autre bout du monde
que pour celles
que nous ne connaissons
que trop bien
pour les croiser tous les jours
avec toutes leurs failles,
toutes leurs faiblesses
qui nous demandent des efforts.
ne pas partager l'évangile,
ne pas confronter les autres.
Et c'est un point très important.
La peur du rejet
nous empêche de confronter
ou en tout cas
nous empêche parfois
de confronter le péché
chez les autres.
Et je pense que c'est une crainte
très présente
et très nocive
pour l'Église.
Elle est dangereuse
parce qu'elle prend souvent
des apparences de douceur,
de compassion,
d'amour,
mais en réalité
ce qu'elle cache
c'est un amour de soi
et une crainte
du regard des autres.
Nous ne voulons pas être perçus
comme des personnes dures,
comme ceux qui reprennent,
comme ceux qui confrontent.
La passivité dans nos relations
c'est un autre signe
de cette peur du rejet.
Nous attendons
que les autres fassent
le premier pas
pour servir,
pour aimer,
pour se réconcilier.
Nous attendons
qu'ils avancent vers nous
pour que cette peur intérieure
que nous avons
que personne ne veuille de nous
soit enfin apaisé.
Nous ne sommes pas intentionnels,
nous sommes passifs,
nous sommes consommateurs
dans ce domaine.
Et peut-être
certains membres
de BN
font des choses
en se disant
ou passent du temps
avec certaines personnes
en se disant
que c'est comme ça
qu'on devient
un bon membre d'Église
aux yeux des autres.
Est-ce que vous faites
vos bonnes œuvres
pour Dieu
ou pour les hommes ?
Est-ce que les faire
uniquement devant Dieu
est satisfaisant pour vous,
est suffisant pour vous ?
Et la solution,
ce n'est pas d'arrêter
de faire le bien,
mais c'est de prier
pour un cœur
qui obéit par amour de Dieu,
qui est satisfait
par son approbation
à lui seul
et qui n'a pas besoin
de l'approbation des hommes
et qui n'a pas peur
du rejet
ou qui n'a pas besoin
de cette approbation humaine,
mais qui est satisfait
pleinement
par le regard de Dieu
et son approbation
à lui.
Et enfin,
dans nos paroles,
de nombreux types
de paroles révèlent
une peur du rejet.
La médisance,
dire derrière le dos
des gens
ce que nous ne dirions
jamais en face d'eux.
Nous avons peur
qu'ils nous rejettent
si nous leur disons
en face
ce que nous pensons vraiment.
La flatterie,
la même chose
mais en compliment.
Dire en face
ce qu'on ne dirait jamais
en privé
d'une personne.
La complimenter
alors que nous ne pensons
tout l'inverse.
Le mensonge,
le rejet de la faute,
l'auto-justification,
la manipulation,
tous ces types de paroles
sont des formes
de communication
qui sont issues
de la peur du rejet
ou du besoin
d'être accepté.
Et donc,
maintenant que nous avons vu
différentes manières
dont la peur du rejet
se manifeste,
quelles sont les conséquences
de cette peur
dans notre vie.
Au-delà du fait
qu'elle s'oppose
à la crainte de Dieu
directement,
la peur du rejet
des hommes
peut causer
de grands dégâts
dans notre vie.
Elle nous rend
esclaves des autres.
Le même auteur,
Édouard Welch,
dit
« Être un people pleaser,
donc quelqu'un
qui cherche à plaire aux autres,
à être accepté des autres,
c'est comme avoir
une poignée dans le dos
que d'autres peuvent saisir
pour vous pousser
ou vous tirer
dans tous les sens.
Vous vous rendez
volontairement
esclaves des autres
en vivant ainsi. »
Une autre conséquence,
c'est que
l'amour de la louange,
des compliments,
nuit paradoxalement
à notre capacité
à les recevoir
lorsqu'ils viennent
naturellement.
Ceux dont vous attendez
la reconnaissance
finiront par être
offensés,
voire écoeurés
par l'orgueil
qui motive
en réalité
votre soif
d'approbation.
Et pour aller plus vite
sur les autres
exemples de conséquences,
nous perdons
des récompenses célestes
lorsque nous sommes
plus guidés
par la peur des hommes
que par la crainte
de Dieu.
La crainte du rejet
nous rend aveugles
à notre propre péché
et aussi à celui
des autres
et comme nous venons
de le dire,
nous empêchent
de confronter
le péché des autres
et le nôtre aussi.
Cette crainte du rejet
nous rend vulnérables
à la flatterie
et donc aussi
à la tromperie,
à la manipulation.
La crainte du rejet
nous rend plus enclin
à commettre
d'autres péchés
comme l'hypocrisie,
l'insatisfaction,
la cupidité,
la timidité,
l'orgueil,
l'indécision
et elle peut même
nuire physiquement
et psychologiquement
dans certains extrêmes.
Douleurs gastriques,
stress,
maux de tête,
fatigue intense,
dépression,
saut d'humeur,
instabilité émotionnelle,
etc.
Et la réponse,
quelle est la réponse
à la peur du rejet ?
C'est de reconnaître
honnêtement que,
oui,
nous méritons
d'être rejetés.
Nous méritons
d'être rejetés
par Dieu.
Non pas par un club privé
ou un groupe social,
mais par quelqu'un
de bien plus important
et digne que cela
par Dieu lui-même.
Et pourtant,
Jésus a été rejeté
pour que nous soyons
acceptés par Dieu.
Jésus a été rejeté
à notre place
pour que nous soyons
acceptés,
réconciliés,
adoptés par Dieu.
lui-même méprisait
et rejetés des hommes,
Esaïe 53.
Il peut pleinement
compatir à notre rejet
par les hommes,
Hébreux 4.
Et grâce au rejet
qu'il a volontairement
accepté de son propre père,
nous sommes acceptés
et adoptés
par Dieu.
Éphésiens 2.
Voilà pour
la peur du rejet.
Je m'arrête
pour une ou deux questions
avant de terminer.
C'est un péché
de timidité.
Je savais que ça viendrait.
En fait,
c'est un péché
si ça nous empêche
de faire des choses
que Dieu nous demande.
Donc,
après,
il y a plein de...
C'est un spectre,
c'est un mot à la mode.
Il y a plein d'intensité.
Il ne faut pas confondre
non plus timidité
et introverti
ou réverver,
des choses comme ça.
Mais par exemple,
c'est déjà arrivé
que des personnes
mettent en avant
leur timidité
ou leur aspect
très introverti
pour ne pas venir
à l'église
ou ne jamais participer
au temps de communion fraternelle
ou venir au culte
qu'une fois le dimanche.
C'est bien une fois le dimanche.
Oh, elle est nulle.
Une fois par mois.
Parce que sinon,
c'est trop pour elles.
Parce qu'elles sont timides,
parce qu'elles sont introverties.
Donc,
en soi,
dans une certaine mesure,
ça peut être un trait de caractère.
Je veux dire,
c'est évident
qu'il y en a
qui sont plutôt extravertis,
d'autres plutôt réservés,
exubérants.
Enfin, voilà.
Et dans les personnes extraverties,
ça peut aussi les amener
à contredire
la volonté de Dieu
dans leur vie.
Voilà.
On pourrait trouver des exemples.
Donc,
c'est juste que,
oui,
dans certaines mesures,
ça peut nous pousser.
si on ne lutte pas
dans la mesure du nécessaire,
si c'est vraiment
une timidité extrême,
ça peut nous amener
à désobéir à Dieu.
Comme des exemples
que j'ai donnés.
En fait,
quand on fait
l'intersection
dans les prières,
j'ai du mal à,
je voudrais bien prier,
donc.
Mais j'ai du mal,
je vais prier,
je vais prier
et je ne prie pas
parce que j'ai du mal
à prier fort.
Tu peux prier doucement ?
Non,
mais des fois,
j'ai envie de prendre
un sujet de prière.
Oui,
je comprends.
Mais,
je pense que,
déjà,
c'est un premier pas
de le dire simplement
comme tu le fais là.
Et ensuite,
je ne dis pas non plus
que ça doit se régler
du jour au lendemain.
Il y a différentes intensités
puisque là,
on parle de la timidité
qui ont des conséquences
plus ou moins fortes.
La peur de,
oui,
de prendre la parole
en public
ou dans les réunions
d'église,
etc.
Mais je pense qu'il faut,
un,
avoir conscience
de ce que j'ai dit,
que ça peut nous amener
à, du coup,
ne pas obéir
à ce que Dieu nous demande
et c'est ça
qui est le plus important.
Donc,
je pense qu'il faut
que tu puisses prier
dans les réunions d'église.
Ça ne veut pas dire
que tu dois prier
pendant cinq minutes
très fort et à chaque fois
et surtout pas au début,
mais il faut un moment
se lancer,
essayer,
faire une prière très courte,
simple,
sur un sujet simple,
d'intercession.
Et la prochaine fois,
ce sera plus simple
sur juste l'aspect
de parler,
de prier en public.
et c'est juste en,
ça c'est pareil
pour presque tout
dans la vie,
les choses qui sont difficiles
ou pas naturelles pour nous,
il faut se lancer
d'abord humblement
et petit à petit,
on progresse.
Donc,
il ne faut juste
pas utiliser
ce qui peuvent être
des traits de personnalité
tout à fait légitimes
pour ne pas obéir
à ce que Dieu nous demande
de manière évidente
dans sa parole.
Ok,
on va terminer
avec la peur
d'être blessé
ou de souffrir
physiquement
et ou émotionnellement.
Donc,
prenons quelques minutes
pour examiner
cette troisième facette
ou catégorie
de la peur des hommes.
Qu'est-ce qu'on entend
par là ?
Être blessé,
souffrir physiquement,
physiquement,
émotionnellement
et donc
des sous-facettes
de cette facette
en commençant par
le plus évident,
pardon,
la peur du mal physique.
Certaines des souffrances
physiques
les plus douloureuses
ont malheureusement lieu
dans le cercle familial.
Que ce soit
entre conjoints,
entre parents et enfants,
entre frères et sœurs
ou dans d'autres relations
familiales plus larges,
le mal subi
dans ces contextes
engendre
des blessures
et des luttes
qui sont particulièrement
profondes
et qui mettent souvent
du temps
à être guéri.
Pourquoi ?
Eh bien,
parce qu'il s'agit
de relations
qui étaient censées
être marquées
par la plus grande
confiance,
le plus grand amour
et la plus honnête
et la plus honnête vulnérabilité
qu'on peut difficilement avoir
dans le monde
mais qu'on espère avoir
au sein du foyer.
la peur du mal physique.
ça peut aussi être lié
à l'exploitation sexuelle
sous toutes ses formes.
C'est une source de peur
envers autrui.
Le harcèlement
ou l'intimidation,
c'est aussi un autre exemple.
Et même si ça semble parfois,
à force de l'entendre,
un aspect ordinaire
de l'enfance
ou surtout de l'adolescence,
malheureusement,
nous devons apprendre
à nos enfants,
encore une fois,
à craindre Dieu
plus que les autres.
Même face à des enfants
qui sont intimidants
ou qui sont violents.
Mais c'est une réalité.
La crainte d'être harcelé,
intimidé,
que ce soit émotionnellement
ou physiquement.
Plus directement pour le chrétien,
il y a la peur
de la souffrance physique
liée à la proclamation
de l'Évangile.
Bon,
par la providence de Dieu,
nous ne sommes pas directement
concernés par ça
aujourd'hui dans notre pays
mais c'est une réalité
que le chrétien
c'est lorsqu'il le devient
qu'il s'expose
à une persécution physique
voire même à la mort.
Et que dire du théorisme
dans un monde
et une société
même dans notre pays
où les attaques théoristes
sont de plus en plus fréquentes
et médiatisées,
cette peur peut devenir
paralysante.
Donc tu vois,
pour revenir à ce que tu demandais,
c'est normal d'avoir peur
du théorisme
mais si ça finit
par nous empêcher
de sortir de chez nous,
d'aller à l'église,
d'exercer
l'hospitalité
ou d'aller chez les frères
et sœurs
ou d'avoir des activités
normales
qu'on doit avoir,
aller au travail,
ce genre de choses,
ça devient,
ça nous amène à pécher
en fait.
Donc cette peur
du théorisme
par exemple
peut devenir paralysante.
Et
un autre exemple,
le racisme
ou la xénophobie,
cette peur de l'homme
peut se manifester
à la fois comme
une peur du mal physique,
une peur du rejet
dans la société.
Est-ce qu'on craint
certains individus
simplement parce qu'ils ont
une couleur de peau différente
ou des origines différentes ?
Est-ce qu'on se sent
moins en sécurité
selon le groupe ethnique
de personnes
qui est autour de nous
en présence
duquel on se trouve ?
Est-ce qu'on importe
cette peur
dans nos relations
avec les frères et sœurs
de Christ
au sein de l'église ?
Est-ce que vous laissez
cette peur
vous empêcher
d'aimer votre prochain
comme Christ ?
Vous la commandez.
Mais la peur de souffrir,
elle n'est pas seulement physique,
elle est aussi émotionnelle,
intellectuelle, spirituelle,
non physique.
Ce n'est tout simplement
pas vrai que les mots
ne blessent pas.
Un patron,
un conjoint
ou un parent
verbalement abusif
peut provoquer
la même peur des autres
que celle qui est liée
aux agressions physiques.
La charge émotionnelle
et psychologique
peut devenir écrasante
et même se refléter
comme je disais tout à l'heure
par des manifestations physiques
à la fin.
Le harcèlement sexuel
peut aussi
entrer dans cette catégorie
des remarques faites à l'oral,
des messages envoyés.
Ce sont des mots
écrits ou oraux
mais ils ont
les mêmes conséquences.
En tout cas,
ils impactent très négativement
la personne.
Et je pense que c'est important
quand on mentionne
toutes ces situations-là
que de dire
que la Bible
n'enseigne pas
qu'on doit rester,
qu'on doit persévérer
dans des situations abusives.
Si vous vivez
quelque chose
de ce genre-là,
il faut en parler
à un ancien
ou à un frère et sœur
en qui vous avez confiance.
Et lorsque nous considérons
l'attitude que nous devons avoir
face à de telles situations,
nous pouvons prier
pour que Dieu nous donne
la force
parce que nous devons avoir
une force qui vient de lui
de manifester amour
et douceur
envers ceux
que nous craignons,
ceux qui nous font peur.
Dans d'autres cas,
il faudra peut-être
qu'on dise la vérité aussi
avec franchise et fermeté.
Mais la peur d'être blessé
pousse souvent
à deux extrêmes
qui ne sont pas légitimes.
Soit le silence complet,
soit la colère démesurée.
Mais l'Évangile
nous enseigne
une autre voie,
plus équilibrée.
Quelles sont les conséquences
de la peur
d'être blessé ?
Quelles sont
certaines des manières
dont nos vies
sont influencées
par ce type de crainte
des hommes ?
À l'intérieur de nous déjà.
Si cette peur,
elle est liée
à une expérience passée
de blessure physique,
d'abus physiques,
il peut y avoir
une crainte réelle
d'être à nouveau blessé.
Et encore une fois,
cette peur peut nous paralyser,
nous empêcher
de faire des choses
nécessaires dans notre vie.
On peut avoir
un sentiment constant
d'être une victime
et la tentation
de blâmer
ces expériences passées
pour toutes les difficultés
présentes ou futures.
Et cela peut finir
par devenir même
notre identité,
une éternelle victime
des blessures du passé.
Certaines personnes
abusées peuvent,
à l'inverse,
penser qu'elles ont mérité
ce qui leur est arrivé.
Et c'est aussi
un mensonge.
Si vous vous êtes déjà dit
j'ai mérité cet abus
parce que je suis mauvais
ou parce que Dieu
est en colère contre moi,
alors sachez
que ce n'est pas vrai.
Dieu ne fait jamais
le mal,
l'abus est toujours
injuste par définition
et vous ne méritez
pas l'injustice.
Tout pécheur
mérite la justice de Dieu,
mais aucun pécheur
ne mérite l'injustice
qu'elle vienne de Dieu
ou qu'elle vienne des hommes.
Et cela peut aussi
mener à l'auto-apitoiement,
des pensées telles que
si je n'avais pas vécu ça,
ça serait tellement plus facile
pour moi de faire confiance
à Dieu
ou de faire telle chose,
telle chose
qu'il me demande de faire.
Mais tout comme l'orgueil,
l'auto-apitoiement
est centré sur soi
et cherche la sécurité
et la force en soi-même
plutôt qu'en Dieu.
Donc ça,
c'est à l'intérieur de nous,
les conséquences de la peur
d'être blessé
à l'intérieur de nous
et ça a un impact aussi
dans nos relations.
Comment la peur du mal
affecte nos relations ?
Tout d'abord,
nous pouvons être environnés
de honte.
La personne qui a subi
une blessure physique
dans le passé
peut vraiment être recouverte
de cette honte-là.
Une honte,
c'est normal de la ressentir
lorsque nous péchons,
mais dans ce cas précis,
c'est plus complexe.
La personne qui a été victime
du péché,
d'une autre personne,
peut ressentir le besoin
de trouver une raison
pour laquelle elle méritait
ce qui lui arrivait,
comme je l'ai dit juste avant.
Et ça,
c'est vraiment une distorsion,
un mensonge de Satan.
La honte qui perdure
suite à un abus physique
ne doit pas amener la personne
à penser qu'elle méritait
ce qui lui arrivait.
C'est un mensonge
de Satan et de la chair.
La personne qui lutte
avec cette peur des hommes
aura aussi
un autre impact
sur les relations,
probablement du mal
à faire confiance aux autres.
Plus nous craignons,
moins nous aimons.
Plus nous avons peur des autres,
moins nous avons
la capacité
de les aimer.
Enfin,
l'amertume
est une forme
plus profonde
de ces réactions.
Quand on ne se repent pas
de ces mauvaises réponses
que j'ai présentées,
qu'on apporte
à nos souffrances
ou qu'on cherche
à apporter à nos souffrances,
eh bien,
elles peuvent se transformer
en amertume,
que ce soit envers les autres
et même envers Dieu.
Donc,
quelle réponse
a cette peur
d'être blessé ?
La réponse,
c'est tout simplement
l'évangile.
Notre culture
propose généralement
deux types de réponses
à un passif
ou à un présent de souffrance,
soit la réponse
de la victime,
j'ai le droit
de ressentir cela
à cause de ce qu'il
ou de ce qu'elle m'a fait,
à cause de ce que j'ai subi,
ou la réponse stoïque,
c'est-à-dire considérer
que même admettre
une peur,
une blessure,
c'est faire preuve
de faiblesse
et si j'avoue
que j'ai peur
d'être blessé physiquement,
est-ce que ce n'est pas
justement ça
qui va m'exposer
à ce que je crains ?
Donc,
je refuse
de même y penser,
de le confesser,
de parler
de cette souffrance.
Voilà
une autre réponse
que le monde
peut apporter.
Mais aucune
de ces deux vérités
n'est la réponse
de l'évangile.
Alors,
quelle est cette réponse ?
Et voici
trois vérités fondamentales.
Premièrement,
reconnaissez
que la pire
de toutes les souffrances
a déjà été subie.
La mort expiatoire
de Christ
pour des péchés
qu'il n'a pas commis,
mais que ceux
qu'il a créés
ont commis
contre lui.
Et pourtant,
en donnant sa vie,
il n'a pas craint
le mal physique
que ses créatures
allaient lui infliger,
mais il a davantage
fait confiance
et craint son Père Céleste.
Ceux d'entre nous
qui ont subi
des blessures physiques
peut-être
peuvent mieux comprendre
comment Christ a souffert
dans ce domaine précis.
Deuxièmement,
ce Christ
qui nous a aimés
en subissant
le mal ultime,
c'est lui
qui contrôle tout
dans notre vie.
Spurgeon écrit
Dieu est trop bon
pour être cruel
et trop sage
pour se tromper.
Et quand nous ne pouvons pas
suivre sa main,
c'est-à-dire comprendre
ce qu'il fait
dans notre vie,
nous devons faire confiance
à son cœur.
Une réponse évangélique
à la souffrance,
c'est reconnaître
que même si nous ne pouvons pas
expliquer cette souffrance,
justifier cette souffrance,
nous pouvons faire confiance
à Dieu
car ses desseins
sont plus grands
et meilleurs
que les nôtres
et nous savons
qu'ils nous aiment.
Inconditionnellement.
Troisièmement,
l'Évangile
nous conduit
à une compassion
qui nous amène
à voir
ceux qui blessent
les autres
ou ceux qui nous blessent
comme des victimes
de leur propre mal.
Voici comment
Jean Calvin
explique cela.
Nous devrions être affligés
de voir quelqu'un périr,
lui qui a été créé
à l'image de Dieu.
Et rachetés
par le sang
de notre Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Nous devrions être attristés
lorsque la victoire
revient au diable.
Nous devons,
pour ainsi dire,
nous mettre à leur place
afin d'être profondément
touchés par leur souffrance
et mûs par l'amour,
pleurés avec eux.
Voilà la réponse
à cette crainte
d'être blessés.
L'Évangile,
tout simplement.
Et donc,
pour conclure,
peur d'être exposés,
peur d'être rejetés,
peur d'être blessés.
La crainte de Dieu,
vous l'avez vu,
et encore,
on n'a pas tout dit,
peut revêtir
d'innombrables formes.
Et j'espère que cette leçon
vous aura permis
de découvrir
ou de mieux comprendre
certaines de ses facettes.
il ne s'agit pas seulement
des formes les plus grossières.
Au contraire,
cette crainte d'être exposés,
rejetés ou blessés
par les hommes
peut être présente
de manière très subtile,
mais tout aussi grave
et dangereuse
dans notre vie.
Et si les formes
sont nombreuses,
la solution est unique.
Il s'agit de l'Évangile.
Savoir que nous sommes
entièrement
et parfaitement
connus par Dieu
dans toutes nos failles,
toutes nos imperfections,
et pourtant infiniment aimés
et acceptés de lui
en Jésus-Christ
nous permet de ne pas craindre
d'être exposés,
rejetés
ou blessés par les hommes
car lui-même,
Dieu,
ne l'a pas fait.
Donc j'espère que
cette leçon
vous aura en tout cas
donné matière à réfléchir
à là où vous en êtes
en ce qui concerne
la peur des hommes
et comment elle se manifeste
dans votre vie.
Et pour nous tous,
mais en particulier
ceux qui ont le plus souffert
de cela dans leur vie
ou qui aujourd'hui
souffrent le plus de cela,
je prie déjà
pour que cette série
vous apporte des réponses
et vous aide
à vous libérer
de cette crainte des hommes
et pour ceux qui sont concernés
peut-être
de la non-crainte de Dieu.
Et je voudrais terminer
avec ces mots rassurants,
réconfortants
du prophète Esaïe
au sujet
de notre Sauveur Jésus-Christ
qui connaît nos souffrances,
qui les a expérimentées
et surtout
qui les fera disparaître.
Esaïe 53, versets 4 et 5
Cependant,
ce sont nos souffrances
qu'il a portées,
c'est de nos douleurs
qu'il s'est chargé.
Il était blessé
pour nos péchés,
brisé
pour nos iniquités.
Le châtiment
qui nous donne
la paix
est tombé sur lui
et c'est par ces meurtrissures
que nous sommes guéris.
Esaïe 25, verset 8
Il anéantit la mort
pour toujours.
Le Seigneur,
l'Éternel,
essuie les larmes
de tous les visages.
Il ôte l'opprobre
de son peuple
sur toute la terre.
Et enfin,
Apocalypse,
chapitre 21, verset 4
Il essuiera
toute larme
de leurs yeux.
La mort ne sera plus.
Il n'y aura plus
ni deuil,
ni cri,
ni douleur.
Car les premières choses
ont disparu.
Amen.